what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice finding general
solutions to separable differential
equations so let's say that I had the
differential equation dy DX the
derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to e to the X over Y see if you
can find the general solution to this
differential equation I'm giving you a
huge hint it is a separable differential
equation alright so when we're dealing
with a separable differential equation
what we want to do is get the Y's and
the D Y's on one side and then the X is
and the DX is on the other side and we
really treat these differentials kind of
like variables which is a little hand
wavy with the mathematics but that's
what we will do so let's see if we
multiply both sides times y so we're
going to multiply both sides times Y
what are we going to get we're going to
get Y times the derivative of Y with
respect to X is equal to e to the X and
now we can multiply both sides by the
differential DX multiply both of them by
DX those cancel out and we are left with
Y times dy is equal to e to the X DX and
now we can take the integral of both
sides so let us do that so what is the
integral of Y dy well here we would just
use the reverse power rule we would
increment the exponent so it's Y to the
first button so now when we take the
antiderivative it will be Y squared and
then we divide by that incremented
exponent is equal to well the exciting
thing about ezx is its antiderivative is
and its derivative is 2 e to the X is
equal to e to the X plus is equal to e
to the X plus C and so we can leave it
like this if we like in fact this right
over here this isn't an explicit
function Y here isn't an explicit
function of X you could actually say Y
is equal to the plus or minus square
root of 2 times all of this business but
this would be a pretty general
relationship which would satisfy this
separable differential equation
let's do another example so let's say
that we have the derivative of Y with
respect to X is equal to it's equal to y
squared times sine of X pause the video
and see if you can find the general
solution here so once again we want to
separate our wise and our X's so let's
see we can multiply both sides times y
to the negative 2 power y to the
negative 2 y to the negative 2
these become 1 and then we can also
multiply both sides times DX so if we
multiply DX here those cancel out and
then we multiply to DX here and so we're
left with Y to the negative 2 power
times dy is equal to sine of X DX and
now we just can integrate both sides now
what is the antiderivative of Y to the
negative 2 well once again we use the
reverse power rule we increment the
exponent so it's going to be Y to the
negative 1 and then we divide by that
newly incremented exponent so we've
divided by negative 1 well that would
just make this thing negative that is
going to be equal to so what's the
antiderivative of sine of X well it is
you might recognize it if I put a
negative there and a negative there the
antiderivative of negative sine of X
well that's cosine of X so this whole
thing is going to be negative cosine of
X or another way to write this I could
multiply both sides times a negative 1
and so these would both become positive
and so I could write 1 over Y is equal
to cosine of X and actually let me write
it this way plus C I want to forget my
plus C's plus C or I can take the
reciprocal of both sides if I want to
solve explicitly for Y I could get Y is
equal to 1 over cosine of X plus C as
our general solution and we're done that
was strangely fun